اذا هناك مخاطر كما ذكرنا نتيجه الذكاء
الاصطناعي لكن ليس كل شيء قاتم سوقوا
التكنولوجيا واحد من الاسواق المستفيده
خسائر كبيره شهدها القطاع خلال العام
الماضي وبدايه العام الحالي لكن ووافقه
موقع تتبع لايف لتسريح العمال من قطاع
التكنولوجيا منذ بدايه 2022 وجد انه وبعد
ان ارتفعت عمليات التسريح لتبلغ ذروتها في
يناير تراجعت لثلاثه اشهر متتاليه السوق
باتت مستقره لكن لمن الفضل في هذا
الانتعاش التشاد جي بي تي بعد اطلاقه في
نوفمبر الماضي بعد هناك سباق تسلح من قبل
الشركات وفق واشنطن بوست الكل يريد دخول
سوق الذكاء الاصطناعي وبالتالي هم بحاجه
لموظفين
ومبرمجين والدليل انه منذ منتصف ابريل
ارتفعت اعلانات الوظائف التي تطلب مبرمجين
بنسبه 30% وبالتالي ارتفعت ايضا
الاستثمارات 12 مليارا ونصف المليار دولار
استثمارات من قبل الشركات الناشئه في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي من بدايه هذا العام وحتى
الان مقارنه باربعه مليارات ونصف المليار
دولار فقط تم استثمارها في هذا المجال في
العام الماضي
بعد الازمه التي شهدها قطاع التكنولوجيا
في الاشهر الماضيه والتي تمحورت حول
التسريحات الجماعيه تقليص اعداد الموظفين
من الشركات التكنولوجيه الكبرى بدا القطاع
بتشكيل بيئه اكثر استقرارا للعمل في
الشركات التي استغنت عن موظفيها مثل ميتى
ومايكروسوفت وامازون تسارع الان للحق بركب
الذكاء الاصطناعي وبتاثيره على الارباح
المستقبليه وبالتالي يهابون التخلف في هذا
المجال اليوم وبينما تقوم مايكروسوفت ومتى
باستثمارات في هذا المجال يتحول مزاج
الشركات شركات التكنولوجيا من خفض الوظائف
لهادف لزياده الارباح الى سباق التسلح في
مسعى للفوز في المستقبل ربما يقضي الذكاء
الاصطناعي على ملايين الوظائف ولكن
المنتجات والخدمات التي ستسمح بهذا التحول
غير موجوده بعد ويتعين على الشركات ان
تصممها لذا فهي بحاجه لمتمرسين في مجال
التكنولوجيا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات